[Musique]
le challenge des créateurs dévoilent sa
24e édition
un concours qui valorise les demandeurs
d'emploi qui font de la création
d'entreprise une valeur de l'insertion
professionnelle donc les modalités de
cette année pour être éligibles au
concours du challenge des créateurs 2021
24e édition ça va être ouvert donc aux
entrepreneurs qui ont créé leur
entreprise entre le 1er juillet 2010 9
et le 31 décembre 2020 et l'autre
condition sinequanone c'est que le
créateur était demandeur d'emploi donc
au moment de la création et qui donc il
a créé son propre emploi un challenge
qui gardent les mêmes formules cette
catégorie de prix récompensé avec
chacune un lauréat et un finaliste des
dotations financières et de
l'accompagnement stratégique auprès des
partenaires du réseau point chance note
population réunionnaise qui connait
vraiment les effets néfastes du chômage
et ben moi j'ai envie de leur dire
n'ayez pas peur lancez-vous on est là
avec les chambres consulaires on vous
accompagne en vous accompagne sur le
montage des projets on vous accompagne
avec des dispositifs financiers quel que
soit votre âge
il ya des dispositifs financiers au sein
du département il ya des chambres
consulaires qui sont là aussi pour vous
pour vous écouter pour vous accompagner
et à la chambre des experts comptables
qui sont là aussi pour donner des bons
plans d'organisation au niveau la
gestion financière donc osé on compte
aujourd'hui cent quatorze lauréats du
challenge des créateurs depuis son
lancement en 1998 jean roi lear homélie
en fait partie il a gagné en 2020 le
prix de l'innovation pour sa technique
de couverture des toiture en chaume de
vétiver
par rapport aux produits que nous
défendent depuis avant jeudi les
valoriser
et gratifiant et
voilà quoi c'est que c'est que du bonus
quoi les inscriptions sont ouvertes sur
le site du département ou
www.dmij.net 7 4 point fr vous avez
jusqu'au 17 octobre à minuit pour
participer à cette aventure des
créateurs d'entreprise
[Musique]